thanks for coming up Cobin 19 are we
overreacting
at the beginning I thought we were and
we still may be but I it's working and
we have some projections that suggests
it's what we ought to do so we're doing
it and and I've said from the beginning
whatever the CDC says whatever filed she
says I worked a alongside him during the
HIV epidemic and you did yeah it was you
know the guy knows what he's doing they
say California's like we're set in kind
of a kind of the terms of art keys for
talent we're gonna have an explosion in
the next two weeks the models out of
University of Washington suggest that
we're gonna peek in about three weeks so
we're gonna the end of next week cuz
we're gonna see how we're doing because
I think your question is I either say
except we're doing stupid [ __ ] like
we're doing today I do understand how I
come in contact with anybody that where
I could transfer it I don't I'm not
around anybody but that's why we're
plateauing so I mean it when they say we
have this huge boom and it doesn't make
sense doesn't it yeah it does because
nobody is around anybody well do you see
the stats which shows like you know h1n1
and all these other different viruses
that were so much worse yes I had H one
when it was brutal and he killed for it
it was terrible killed so many he killed
40 to 60 rows routinely routinely and it
killed a half a million people and
infected one billion and we weren't
paying you don't even know what happened
no no Bob lemak issued out like a
warning yeah I mean like hey man we need
Cole almost died from it she was 33 at
the time yeah it was time I had it was
sick I got better watch this sick of
[ __ ] for a week kept going I'm like I
[ __ ] know then I got better and then
I got really sick again that's ten years
ago Kovac can do that too but let's be
fair me cope it's dusty anymore
infectious and it does seem to be have a
higher fatality rate in risk populations
and technically I'm in one right it will
no older population over over 16 yeah I
mean she's really a prostate cancer and
hypertension technically I'm in a real
you did write a paper but Judge Scott
syndrome
it still killed a lot of people is he
killing people in their enemies yeah I
was thinking mostly killing older but
it's getting a few you know it's not
it's gonna be you know it's gonna let
this with this where we lose about
30,000 people to the flu every year
right 30,000 right
i'ma send you this and if this is worse
than the flu we should be up around 90
to 100 thousand right so that's what's
probably gonna happen and if we do that
if that happens in such a way that we
don't overwhelm the system success but
h1n1 killed routinely kill people in
their 40 40 40 to 60 and and why wait
well we don't know what is the way these
viruses are why is this one only killing
old people hey this one is something do
it how it binds in the in the lung how
is how is the hydroxychloroquine e
quinine in combination this week
everything is gonna be about testing and
treatment and if we do more widespread
testing if we find out that for instance
more people are immune we find out more
people have it they didn't know it
whatever we're gonna learn more about
where it really is in the community and
then we're gonna learn about
therapeutics and then nobody does this
better than our country man we we figure
out how to treat stuff and we come up
with good plans and good ways of
intervening and if that us know we kill
on that and all the measures of the US
healthcare you know that you know where
we rank relative to some other country
never takes into account something like
this never we do this we flex we get it
done we innovate we figure it out and
and there and if we can really knock the
viral shedding down knock the
hospitalization down knock the ICU use
down then it becomes the flu I need a
lot of ammo I want a well I want solar I
want a log cabin I want two dogs that
are gonna bite somebody and warn me of
intruders
I want to let y'all talk about that for
lunch I know I have I want to be ready
and I got so much hands down its horse
just because me and Brian have been and
people have sent me DMS we like dude you
gotta quit saying that the you know this
virus isn't that dangerous and cuz
people listen you influence people
you'll start getting accused of killing
people
yes you're killing people just for
raising the issue how aggressive should
we be that's important that's an
important question what is that this is
worldwide best from January 1st to March
25th
Korona diagnosis is going up 21,000
deaths by seasonal flu already 113,000
that's by malaria 228,000 that's by
suicides 250,000 traffic fertility and I
think if nothing else these numbers
should help you calibrate your emotional
response to this that's what I'm saying
that's what I know that it's okay that
we the government wants to go to the mat
with this and control them they feel
they need to good we're all doing this
collectively let's follow our leaders
let's do what they tell us to follow CDC
for sure but don't freak out and don't
read the newspapers and don't watch
cable news they are just trying to watch
us try they're trying to spin people
away I've never seen a stick up for drew
a lot you know I do online because Drew
is one of the first medical
professionals that's in the media that
was saying like you need to relax a
little bit and that the media thing
you're responsible about it people
extrapolate that into saying dr. Drew's
saying it's not serious and all I always
say oh this is enough out you listen to
Falchi listen if I know I've seen like
this is the thing that bothers me it's
like I'm gonna do my best to protect
myself and protect my family I'm gonna
listen to every single rule that has
brought down upon me by the United
States government but the you know the
the media has been wildly irresponsible
and they have definite like we can all
the response they're just powerful
they're they're using this as an
opportunity to save themselves because
it was a failing business model up until
you know three or four why why this what
why me is how literally don't touch me I
just now I've crime but what's
fascinating is why this particular virus
and this this I've never seen in my
lifetime there's this kind of reaction
yeah what happened I we well we created
a panic that's what that I could see it
coming I when they when they started
reporting on China thought oh my god
they have no idea what they're reporting
on we have no idea of knowing what's
coming out of China what's really going
on
just shut up until we figure out what's
going on oh no it's the end of the world
drama distrain it here it comes who was
saying this was it every scene no no
that was my point every media outlet you
can imagine shut up shut up shut up
you're gonna make this worse and now
we've you know whatever the collective
spirit
level higher three times let's be fair
if we just let it fly it would exceed
the ability of our hospital to meet the
needs and this serious thing we've never
had anything like that before I think
it's not in recent history and so it's
worth making a giant effort to prevent
that from happening and once we're in
we're kind of into that effort and you
know do we need to completely shut
everything down I think we could have
been smarter about it and use
technologies and better tests I hope and
hopefully they won't be a flu you know
it'll be something really dangerous this
is dangerous for some people and hard to
predict for whom it's been and let's be
fair it's bad it's a nasty flu I mean if
you talk to anybody who's been on a
ventilator but through it it's awful
yeah and you can't and you crash fast
and you get a RDS and that's a horrible
complication there's lots of lung
scarring and problems down the line and
when people spend multiple days on the
ventilator before they get off if they
get off so it's a big deal if you pray
have you seen the some of the footage of
the hospitals if you if you watch the
media they show just it's packed and
it's chaos yeah and then you go the
hospital it's really not like that cuz
they're showing pictures of Italy not
our house correct they were they were
pretending then what was going to be
held to kill but those journalists
should be put in jail and how about
there being a response for the people
report couple dies from taking cola-cola
loreen or whatever because Trump said so
no that's the headline you take one down
you're like they clean fish tank same
fish tank cleaner I just think like this
is definitely adding to people's fear
and I'm not saying that's not something
to fear but I do think perspective
you're asking perspective it's not they
get a present and by the way this
hydroxychloroquine really might work
yeah and if we get some data towards the
end of the week I mean that I'll change
everything yeah yeah that'd be really
cool I've always appreciated very much
your perspective I listen to it my
sister's obsessed with that she sent me
your thing about going about your
business wash your hands listen to CDs
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[ __ ] desert city